I know but here's the thing with you and
and I say this openly I don't you're
literally one of the funniest people
I've ever seen
yeah you that's so nice thank you a
legitimately talented like you know when
you watch certain people even stand up
say got you go the writing's good or arm
you know but sometimes I'll look at
somebody go wow that person is
legitimately talented you know I don't
throw that on a lot but that's one do
you have a positive memory of Bobby or
was it just the drug laced debauchery oh
I have I want to know what he was like
in his 30s cuz I only know him in his
forties and he seems a little bit more
settled and I I have this sick curiosity
for how I wonder and I imagine if I
would have gotten along with him at that
age Bobby was lovely we would sit
outside the building yeah we would sit
outside the building like just between
whatever rehearsals or whatever and have
a cigarette yeah sometimes you know and
just sit down there and we would just
have life conversations you know I would
I remember you feeling insecure and
worried about it and talking to you and
telling you it's gonna be alright
you know I remembered a time just before
stepping out onto stage at one of the
live shows and you were backstage with
me and you were freaking out like right
right behind the door we were about to
enter mmm you know and I was just I
remember that moment very vividly you
know that I would just like Bobby you
lucky son of a [ __ ] you get to go out
there and play in front of these people
with me yeah like let's just go out and
have fun yeah that's all you have to do
right that's not that's not hard that's
that's just abandon yourself to what's
good for you you know so we had a we
have a lot of conversations we do a lot
of really sweet conversations you know
it's like it isn't all
the crazy that you know I led in with
yeah it wasn't it really wasn't that
yeah you know we've had good no dinners
and you know and all that we used to go
after lives we used to go to that one
French place on Las Palmas that was
called there was one over there that we
should go every frog for every lie but
it was cool fun and then and then
everyone would go like you know all the
writers and producers and also some
friends family whatever it was a fun
night but um this one too it's here's
how I how why I can say that though is
because you know when you're sitting
there and you're watching like her play
Lorraine or whatever and then they do a
pass where it's like all improvised or
do what you want to do yeah and she's
just how crazy like so just in terms of
adding information that quickly it you
know in in a live environment with the
cameras on and you're sitting there
indian-style going wow I've never you
know I mean I didn't grow up with ya
sketch you know but you're learning so
fast and you're trying to absorb
everything right and then it's just like
watching someone like that you go holy
[ __ ] like that was insane you know like
Keegan would do that to Keegan keys
would do coach Hines and then do a tank
where he just the whole thing is
completely and utterly different but
also like somebody had written it like
it took a week and wrote it yeah but it
wasn't it was all improvised and you
just kind of go oh [ __ ] yeah but anyway
um and then so when she was doing
dreamcourt that was one of the sales
they try to sell me right because I know
Nick nixed on this podcast before yeah
yeah and he's like whoa did our show
said I did it and then when I was on
doing it and they go we're doing another
episode in a week and Moe will be here I
go right me and
that wasn't supposed to be in it I go
right me into that thing and they go you
want to come back I go yeah you have to
give me lines I'll just show up and so I
came and just you work with you know you
were you were my glitter that day your
glitter really you were my glitter than
way why uh well because I need you why
am i your glitter so needy enough that
hasn't changed
here we go Bobby
[Laughter]
[Music]